- [Gary] Hey, man.
How are you?
- Good, how you doin'?
- [Gary] Good.
Wow, if Neilann's
you're spirit animal--
- [Jacob] You like that?
She's a beast though.
- She's a beast.
She is a beast.
How you doin'?
- Good.
- [Gary] How's work?
- Great.
- [Gary] Good. Tell me.
- People I'm working
with are the best.
Very, very happy with
who I ended up with.
- [Gary] Yeah, you
ended up with an A team.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's the truth.
- Everyone I work
with is unbelievable.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And first job out
of college is sweet.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I feel like I got lucky.
- [Gary] It worked out.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And so, what are
you working on right now?
- We just finished up
some always on content.
- [Gary] Yep.
- But we're transitioning so
we're now doing more campaign
work so I'm doing less--
- [Gary] On what brands?
- On (censored).
I'm also on (censored).
- [Gary] Yep.
- Those I just do
community management.
- [Gary] Yep.
- But I'm, that's the best about
them is since they're so solid
they let me do other things.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Across the board, all of them,
they're outperforming higher so
they let the person
under them--
- [Gary] 100%.
- That's the best part about it
and that's why I think it's good
for me 'cause I'm
working on a ton of shit.
- [Gary] It's like how we know.
It's a sports analogy.
You get drafted by
a great team,--
- [Jacob] Yeah, it's a fit.
- and, yeah, it's a fit.
- [Jacob] I got lucky.
- It's good.
It's good to get
lucky sometimes.
What about and what about the
macro culture of the company?
Outside of your day-to-day?
- That's what I mean.
I don't really
have to compare to--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- because my first job.
- [Gary] That's a good point.
- Talking to other people,--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- just humans, I've met, I've
talked to humans before and
I have a good
experience with humans.
- [Gary] No, (laughs) yeah.
- I mean, yeah, it's great.
And I would say coming into this
it has exceeded my expectations.
But again, I have
little to compare to.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- But I mean, yeah.
I would hang out with most of
these people outside the office.
- [Gary] Yeah, and the
basketball stuff has been great.
- It's huge.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- It's been great.
It's great.
Even outside of
work, just to run.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- It's awesome.
I think the fact that it's
at six in the morning--
- [Gary] Eliminates, yeah.
- Yeah. It really does though.
- [Gary] People
that want to be there.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] For sure.
What can I answer for you?
- [Jacob] Question,
building communities.
Advice between...
- [Gary] What is that, DRock?
- [DRock] I have no idea.
- [Gary] Go ahead,
I'm listening.
- [Jacob] Content,
outside of blogs,
SEO versus just social.
- For the purpose of?
- [Jacob] A start up that is
just trying to gain a following.
- Cool.
So is this like for
your side hustle?
Your friends or your guys'?
- [Jacob] Yeah.
- You can be specific with me.
I'm working with
guys like Brandon,
guy you know as John Henry.
- Yep. What is it?
- [Jacob] His personal brand.
- Who's? Brandon's?
- [Jacob] Yeah.
- The kid we played with today?
- [Jacob] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What's he do?
- [Jacob] He does menswear.
(inaudible)
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- [Jacob] Yeah, he's good.
- You're gonna get
more bang for your buck,
I mean, there's so much,
so what's good about search and
blogs is there's
far more guaranteed
singles and doubles.
What's great about social is
there's so many more potential
for home runs and grand slams
and so it just depends on how
you want to play it.
It comes down to
economics, a lot of times.
- [Jacob] Right.
I think that's a good thing.
- And menswear is all going to
over-index visually so that's
where Facebook and Instagram
and things of that
nature are gonna--
- [Jacob] For sure.
- Go ahead.
- [Jacob] If you want to
build a deeper community,
wouldn't you agree that
you'd have to give real content?
So, is that why SEO and Google
people are searching for
their problems.
- [Gary] Yeah, I mean look.
Look, search is real.
- You think you're getting
real to who you want to talk to.
- [Gary] Real people meaning?
- The specific people that have,
are searching for their problem
and provide their solution.
- [Gary] Yeah, I mean, search
is the great intent marketing
vehicle of our time.
I have a weird rash.
- [Jacob] Right.
- How to solve
this bike problem.
- [Jacob] Right.
- So what search is incredible
for is I have a specific thing
I want to scratch right now.
And I'm going to
go to this site,
Google, and I'm
going to find something.
What's great about social is
you're interested in basketball
and it comes to you.
- [Jacob] Okay.
- It's passive versus
going on the offense.
What's great about social is
it's got built-in word of mouth.
So you are an individual trying
to solve your fashion problem in
a menswear thing, you're never
gonna tell anyone about
what you're doing.
There's no inherent word
of mouth brand building.
Whereas in social if you
discover that I'm interested
in that, I see it,
the amplification percentages
are very high.
Even built-in.
Instagram, you double tap
something your friends look at
what your liking.
- [Jacob] Right.
- It's just just a
very, very, very,
very different insular
versus outward thing.
For me that's why social has
been so big for small brands.
They don't have anything yet.
And so they rely so
much on word of mouth.
- [Jacob] What about
getting a community?
For example, your
community is strong.
Down to comment.
Down to do whatever.
- Yes.
- [Jacob] Essentially
anything you say.
- Yes.
- [Jacob] But I think that's
because you give deeper content.
- Yeah, I think the
variable of the subject matter,
what the person is
bringing to the table.
If this is a menswear product
that has 89% of its overall
macro energy, in
Brandon's heart and brain--
- [Jacob] Right.
- is to sell this
product, if that's 89%,
he's gonna have
an 11% community.
The reason I have such a big
community is I'm the reverse.
That's what people
don't understand.
It's playing a
marathon versus a sprint.
When you don't have the luxury
like Brandon probably doesn't of
waiting two years
to monetize,--
- [Jacob] Right.
- whatever he's doing, you go
in for the sale and what happens
when you go in for the sale is
the people on the
other side of it feel it.
It's a value exchange game.
- [Jacob] Long-term, short-term.
- That's exactly right.
And I sit here on a pedestal
because I've been able to put in
the work for 20 years and I have
the leverage now to do that.
- [Jacob] Right.
- But day one it is hard.
Day one 22-year-old
Gary trying to sell wine,
I don't know if I would've
had a 97% percent you,
3% me strategy.
As a matter fact,
I know I didn't.
It was more 50-50 but
I even then knew wasn't 98, 2
and that's what most people do.
Why are you producing content?
'Cause you really
want to sell your shit.
If you want to sell your
shit in the short term,
your content and your
energy to ploys that behavior.
If you think about I'm going to
try to stay alive for two years
and the content I'm going to
put out is just going to build
relationship and then I'll be
able to monetize that some way
in two years, your
content looks very different.
All of a sudden you're in
there answering people's
fashion questions.
You're just thinking
about it differently.
See where I'm going?
- [Jacob] Yeah, definitely.
My big question,
22-year-old advice
New York indie digital game,
what about that?
- It comes down
to your ambition.
I think the answer
is far more like
what you want to happen in life?
And then how you
want to get there?
So you know, the
serendipity of being that this,
if you're in digital games, you
stepped into shit because you
stepped into the best place at a
time when a lot of people didn't
realize that that was the case.
Which means you have just
disproportionate value.
You know, everybody's
gonna want to work you now.
- [Jacob] Right.
- But they're gonna come
in at a different company.
You have a lot of value and
you came in as employee number
five-who knows what
number you came in, right?
Well, guess what?
People that came in number 30
and 40 have even
more value, right?
So I think it comes down to
do you want to have your own
agency, do you want
to have, it's amazing.
And I'll give you a
really good piece of advice.
It's been interesting to watch
22-year-olds that have asked me
that question who tell me want
to have their own shop and
I would say I'll help you.
You'll learn so much here.
I'll be an external mentor.
We'll get to know each other.
You work here for 5 to 7 years
and give me a lot of blood and
sweat and tears I'll
even help you even more.
Financially, relationships.
It's been interesting to see how
many of those 22-year-olds are
now 26, and now say to me,
"I don't want my own shop.
"I fell in love.
"I like my
work-life balance here.
"I believe in you.
"I like the idea of making
"$200,000 a year
and having that life."
Other people went the other way.
"Like I don't know, I want to
work at Vayner my whole life and
"make $100,000," and
now they're like,
"Wait a minute, maybe
I can have my own."
So I think the one thing to
understand is 22-year-old Jacob
and 27-year-old Jacob and
33-year-old Jacob are
very different dudes.
I wouldn't
cripple yourself with,
don't let your ambition
create and whatever ambition,
whether the most extreme.
I want to buy the Jets
or whatever it may be,
don't let it be in
permanent marker.
- [Jacob] That's
pretty good advice.
- And I think the other
thing is relationships matter.
- [Jacob] Yeah.
- That's life.
And so the thing we
started this meeting with,
I would highly recommend
spending 30 minutes in the
cafeteria every day and
working and saying hello.
- [Jacob] Sure.
- It's just insane
that Chris, right there,
is the guy that might create an
opportunity for you and how many
people will not even say hello.
- [Jacob] Yeah.
- So I'd be so more
social professional.
- [Jacob] That makes sense.
- Yeah.
There's so much value here.
The greatest thing I've created
here is that it's easy to say
hello to somebody here.
- [Jacob] For sure.
- That's what your
friends are telling you.
That they work in a place where
you can't fucking say
hello to anybody.
- [Jacob] Yes.
- That's not allowed.
That's the horse shit out there.
- [Jacob] Yes.
- That's the best thing here.
So then do it.
- [Jacob] I like that.
- It's really, real.
- [Jacob] Yeah.
- And it creates
different opportunities.
Even if you life goal was
to work here for 37 years,
even internally it'll
create opportunities.
- [Jacob] Sure.
Yeah.
- Go ahead.
- [Jacob] Yeah.
He got a new job but he's
looking for other stuff.
Digital sports, whatever,
any advice for the
direction he should go?
- Again, whether it's
22-year-old (censored) it comes
down to does he want to
work for 13 more years,
eight, three.
Where is he financially?
It's so hard, that's why you
have to know those things
but I would give...
Listen, I've come to really like
you if you (censored) come and
jame for me for
15 minutes, 20 minutes,
I'd be willing to do that.
I have a lot of relationships.
You know?
I'd be more happy to help him
but I need to know what the
fuck he cares about.
- [Jacob] For sure, for sure.
- If he's like dude, I just want
to go three more and I'm gone.
- [Jacob] No, no,
no, he's interested.
- Cool.
- [Jacob] He's working for--
- Good, if he's in the game,
then I think it comes down to a
financial thing of
what can he afford.
Does he want to be executive, so
kid we're recruiting right now,
his dad took a huge pay cuts as
an operations SVP to be the first
SVP operations at...
He was right.
He left half his salary on the
table 'cause he could afford to.
And that stock turned into the
greatest nest egg of all time.
Became rich!
Let alone successful.
So I think (censored)
can go through that too.
Out of (censored) he's needs
to decide if he's gonna go for
eight to 15 more, can he afford
to make $80,000 at Bleacher
Report versus 235 at NBC Sports.
- [Jacob] Right.
- Got it?
- [Jacob] Yes.
- That's how has
to think about it.
That's a
black-and-white decision.
And then if you can afford it,
then I would push him very
heavily to
more fun, more autonomy,
more upside, better energy--
- [Jacob] For sure.
- and if he can't, then you got
a look at the alternative and
try to find the best version
of that in that
corporate environment.
- [Jacob] That's awesome.
- Yep. Cool.
- [Jacob] 'Preciate it.
- Good seeing you, man.
Talk to you soon.
- [Jacob] Yeah. Have a good one.
- You too.